uh Donald Trump has had a mental
breakdown over being called out
accurately for the things he said about
the Constitution now let's back up just
a moment to make sure we're all on the
same page reporting accurately described
Donald Trump's demands for a newer a new
election or to be reinstated as
president of the United States based on
the hunter Biden Twitter files which
were a complete and total flop
in a post on Truth social which we
looked at yesterday and I will show you
again Donald Trump actually says quote a
massive fraud
a massive fraud of this type and
magnitude allows for the termination of
all rules regulations and articles even
those found in the Constitution he said
it he clearly said it Trump was
criticized for saying it because it's
dangerous and it's outrageous and it's
the metaphorical defecation on the
Constitution that he was accurately
described as partaking in and Trump
flipped out yesterday on Truth social
truth essential lying trying to deny and
of course typing in all capital letters
this is starting to be Kanye West level
stuff or maybe the Kanye West stuff is
actually Donald Trump level stuff I
don't know take a look at this insane
rant Trump says quote
the fake news is actually trying to
convince the American people that I said
I wanted to terminate the Constitution
this is simply more disinformation and
lies just like Russia Russia Russia and
all of their other hoaxes and scams what
I said was that when there is massive
and widespread fraud and deception as
has been irrefutably proven in the 2020
presidential election by the way it
hasn't steps must be immediately taken
to right the wrong Only Fools would
disagree with that and accept stolen
elections Maga and then we enter all
caps insanity quote simply put if an
election is irrefutably fraudulent it
should go to the rightful winner or at a
minimum be redone we're open and blatant
fraud is involved there should be no
time limit for change Trump continuing
in all caps we want people who quote
legitimately he won the election I don't
know why he puts legitimately in quotes
I don't know that the quotes mean what
he thinks they mean we want people who
legitimately won the election to lead
our country not people who had to cheat
in order to win that I agree with and we
got that person Trump is like your
conspiracy theorist uncle
except instead of being some random guy
that you see twice a year
it's the former president of the United
States who's putting this stuff out and
of course
Trump did say the thing that now he says
he didn't say he may not have said
terminate the Constitution but he said
terminate parts of it when you want the
original post was quote
so with the big with the revelation of
massive and widespread fraud and
deception in working closely with big
tech companies the DNC and the Democrat
Party
do you throw the presidential election
results of 2020 out and declare the
rightful winner or do you have a new
election a massive fraud of this type
and magnitude allows for the termination
of all rules regulations and articles
even those found in the Constitution
our great quote Founders did not want
and would not condone false and
fraudulent elections he said it
it was dangerous it horrified the world
and even some Republicans he was called
out
now he's denying it because he's Furious
this is getting worse and worse and
worse and many Republicans don't even
believe that this is disqualifying in
terms of his chance or possibility at
once again being president of the United
States
will have the posts the clips and all of
it on our Instagram which you can find
at David Pacman show also make sure
you're subscribed on our YouTube channel
we are heading towards 2 million
subscribers on YouTube that's
youtube.com slash the davidpackman show
parents in the audience if you're like
me you're looking for fun new things to
do with your kids meaningful enriching
but fun enough to keep them engaged
every month our sponsor Mel science
sends you a box with science experiments
that combine Hands-on Physical
components with virtual and augmented
reality learning science doesn't need to
be boring it doesn't need to be
difficult many kids are Hands-On
Learners who absorb the most through
activities like these it's perfect for
homeschooling ages five through High
School five different subscriptions to
choose from chemistry physics stem math
or medicine Mel science sent me the
chemistry of monsters box where you grow
a black monster from sugar and make a
huge foam eruption in a flask but you're
actually learning about carbon dioxide
and unstable carbonic acid we had a ton
of fun with it the VR components are
awesome too it is really clear how this
helps kids tune into what they are
learning and my audience gets 50 off
your first month go to melscience.com
and use the code Pacman the link is down
below